if you'd like to support more content on
the channel and get some epic anime
merch check out our online store anime
out Broadcom we have original designs
that were done exclusively for us by pro
manga artist Cuusoo mari including this
dream big work hard
hasta shirt for your fan of the channel
feel free to use the discount code
uproar 25 at checkout for an instant 25%
off what is up everybody its Anna Mak
here for anime uproar and today we will
be discussing the latest watershed
moment in the black clover story a
massive development that just changed
the game and set up perhaps the most
epic conflict in the story so far and
that's saying a lot
the next major villain is confirmed to
be the strongest demon yet in the black
Lawler story and in order to face him
all the most powerful magic Knights of
both the clover and Hart Kingdom need
months of intense training we just got
some major reveals some important
developments and a setup for a brand new
Ark so let's get into it and break all
of it down right here in this video if
you enjoyed the black clover content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't make sure to
turn on all notifications YouTube will
bury a lot of our videos it's just the
way it goes and finally yes of course
this video will contain manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so now that Gaia Undine and
beaver girl are totally BFFs with Austin
the crew all the guests from the clover
Kingdom are summoned to the Hart Kingdom
palace where they are reunited with
hasta by the way last week we had a poll
on our Twitter at anime uproar about how
I should refer to Laura Pacheco the
clumsy ruler of the Hart Kingdom the
choices were queen princess priestess
and beaver girl
and of course beaver girl one with like
60% of the vote so that is why I will be
calling her beaver girl from now on if
you want to take part in future polls
similar to this one or you just want to
stay up to date with
the channel and with the latest updates
on black clover please be sure to follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar and if you don't feel like
actually typing out at anime uproar on
Twitter or Instagram you can just click
the direct link it's right there in the
description for both the most Sun Noel
and Finn roll are all glad to see that
hasta is alright as they are brought
into the palace by Gaia where they meet
the majestic Queen for the very first
time
beaver girl is wearing her regal robes
and she does look quite beautiful
not only that her amazing magic power is
clearly noticeable and Noel is shocked
when she senses it up close surprising
no one Finn role instantly starts
swooning over Bieber girl and then he
starts screaming and hitting his set on
the ground because he feels guilty for
yet again letting his eyes and
imagination wander away from Lady
finesse Bieber girl then speaks asking
the citizens of the clover Kingdom to
lend her their power but then instead of
remaining regal and dignified she also
drops to the ground
apparently slipping and hitting her nose
in the process Undine is all like WTF
flora Pacheco you're royalty you have to
show something that he but I still love
you and Gaia just face BOMs
saying that he knew that letting beaver
girl actually meet everyone in public
would be a bad idea but after that whole
comical exchange we get to the good
stuff
the clover Kingdom guests ask why Bieber
girl needs their power and she responds
by saying that although only tier 1 and
tier 0 mages stand a chance against a
demon even they are unable to finish off
demons so for example the spirit
guardians of the Hart Kingdom use magic
power that borrows the mana of nature
but even they cannot completely defeat a
demon the difference between Hart
Kingdom and clover Kingdom magic is that
Hart Kingdom magic uses the power of
natural mana and clerking the magic uses
unnatural magic like manifesting objects
out of thin air or even manipulating
space Bieber girl says that these
diverse forms of magic gave rise to both
McGhee Kula the demon and to the
individuals who stand a chance in a
fight against the demon such as for
example Julius and Yami at this point it
would be good to mention that beaver
girl clearly knows a lot about the
clover Kingdom and its citizens and she
seems to know that Julius lost most of
his power she also states something very
interesting she says that if we're just
talking about conventional magic scaling
both austin Sacre would rank low but
because asta has anti magic and Sacre
uses ceiling magic and forbidden magic
they both possess incomprehensible power
their power cannot be measured by the
standard tier system so Beiber girl
calls their abilities dark tier dark
tier definitely sounds pretty cool but
the problem is that by having this new
dark tier that doesn't fit on the
existing tier system you are already
rendering the tier system pretty much
useless only a few chapters after
introducing it but hey what are you
gonna do Bieber girl wants Austin secret
tool and these dark tier powers to her
so that they can all face Maggi Cola
together no Allen hasta decided to reach
out to Yami and see whether he would be
on board with this whole idea after all
Yami is their designated superior but
unsurprisingly the magical call reaches
Yami right when he is trying to take a
dump this whole getting interrupted on
the toilet thing happens to Yami a lot
so clearly the man has a very healthy
metabolism Yami tells them to call him
later because he currently has bigger
problems so they decide to contact marks
using a magical communication tool just
as marks answers chibi Julius
immediately pops into the frame to ask
about the hard kingdoms ruler and her
magic which is exactly what we have come
to expect from Julius Julius is 100%
onboard with helping out bieber girl in
her struggle against Miggy Kula since he
feels that this experience will provide
valuable magical knowledge and he even
offers to come along and help out
personally bieber girl is happy that the
negotiations went so smoothly but she
also has some bad news
apparently Maggi Kula is even stronger
than the kotodama demon that the mages
of the clover kingdom defeated not too
long ago which means that mcgee cola is
the strongest demon that we have met so
far if you'll recall Asta's demon had
referred to the kotodama demon as his
superior so we can assume that oz does
demon isn't as strong as either the
kotodama demon or me
kula at least not so far at this point
in the story but clearly Mickey Cola is
actually the strongest of the three even
stronger than the previous major villain
in the series beaver girl says to Austin
friends that as they are right now
McGee Cola could kill them all easily
and so they are going to need a massive
power boost in order to stand a chance
against the demon Astor recalls how much
effort went into defeating the kotodama
demon and they even had help from licked
and Lumiere something that they cannot
count on this time around on top of that
the recent shellacking of the diamond
kingdom by the spade kingdoms mages or
possibly even just one single mage shows
that the clover kingdom magic Knights
have no choice but to get a lot stronger
very quickly
Julius understands the severity of the
situation as cheery and positive as he
really is it is clear that this
situation with Mickey Cola and the Hart
Kingdom is no joke
their current predicament is definitely
a serious one beaver girl then confirms
that Meggie Kula resides inside the
spade Kingdom and that he is using the
people of the Spade Kingdom to build up
his power we don't know how exactly he
is using the citizens of spade but McGee
Kula has apparently been able to harness
the power of the entire kingdom and
combine it with his demon powers in
order to eventually conquer the other
kingdoms and the invasion of the Diamond
Kingdom has already initiated this
sequence of events beaver girl reminds
everyone that as a result of her curse
she only has one year to live so they
must take the fight to Meggie Kula while
they still have her immense powers at
their disposal
once she dies their chances of winning
against the demon will be even lower
within the next six months the spirit
guardians of the Hart kingdom all ranked
zero tier in terms of magic power will
help the guests from the clover Kingdom
to get even stronger they will train
together and do their best to create a
powerful heart clover Alliance that will
be capable of standing up to the demon
Kingdom of spade and their ruthless
leader Meggie Kula the strongest of all
the demons all the strongest mages of
both kingdoms will have to prepare
themselves because this coming battle
could easily be the most
big battle in the entire series the
final page of the chapter reveals a
time-skip six months has passed and we
see you non-self his wind spirit flying
over a vast mountainous region since
below you know we appear to see the
three-eyed skull of lifts giant demon
form it is safe to assume that this is
happening on the outskirts of hog a
village the final page also announces
the start of a brand new arc in the very
next chapter which we can only assume is
the mega Kula arc an arc which will pit
the strongest mages of the clover and
Hart kingdoms against the strongest
demon mega cola and the entire demon
kingdom of spade Wow this chapter really
did absolutely change the game when it
comes to the future of black clover the
heart clover Alliance was confirmed
Meggie Kula was confirmed as the
strongest demon who is using the entire
Spade kingdom to increase his strength a
six-month time skip occurred a new arc
was announced Yami took a dump all major
and game-changing developments in the
black Laura's story personally I am very
excited about this I did think that the
whole heart kingdom subplot made a 180
turn very quickly and they went from
potential ruthless villains to clumsy
and comical allies within like one or
two chapters but with that said every
since Maggie claw was first introduced
several chapters ago I've been saying
that he will be the true villain and
that the next major arc will be focused
around him and the Spade Kingdom
now all the pretenses have been dropped
and the cat is out of the bag Meggie
Kula and the Spade Kingdom have been
built up as truly powerful opponents
Miggy colas apparently the strongest
demon we have meant to date and one mage
from the Spade Kingdom who probably
isn't even Maggie Cola maybe he's just
an ally or a subordinate of Meggie Cola
was able to destroy an entire Diamond
Kingdom army
we know that austa you know and the
mages of both the heart and clover
kingdom have been training intensely for
six months and some of them have been
training with the elite warriors of the
heart kingdom meaning that our heroes in
these last six months have likely
learned new and unique magic techniques
and abilities this really is the perfect
setup for an arc that will actually be
able to live
to the hype of the previous arc that
featured the epic battle against the
kotodama demon many of us were wondering
how you catawba table will possibly be
able to raise the stakes further after
that previous epic showdown but I have
to say that it looks like he has done it
again
it will all depend on how the story will
unfold from here but we've definitely
got a great setup and introduction into
a new arc that will include power boosts
for our favorite characters and new and
even more powerful villains including
the strongest demon I honestly can't
wait to see what happens next and I'm
curious to hear what you guys think
about this next upcoming arc are you
excited and what do you think will
happen next
do you have high expectations of Meggie
cool as a villain and what type of
unique demonic powers do you think that
he will possess
hostes demon has ante magic the kotodama
demon has kotodama magic but what about
McGee Kula is it the power of feeding on
the mana of every person in the Spade
Kingdom or maybe something else let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments below also I still think that
this article revealed that Noelle's
mother is not really dead at least not
in the way that we think but we'll have
to wait and see if you enjoyed the black
lower content right here on this channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime Pro please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications that way
you won't miss any of our future black
clover uploads feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime out pro patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson King's eldest son Hal Cruz
Steelers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitted alibied a karate
Gian Anatoly Kazuki TJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam
Mack makoto-kun and your boys Seth if
you enjoy our videos and you think that
they add some value to your life
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our page and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]